this used to be
so easy but even with quarantine
being cut back for many a flight abroad
is still not worth the effort
lee has postponed spain three times
and instead is off to norfolk with his
family
we want holidays to be as minimal work
as possible and at the moment it
actually feels like more effort to get
out of the country
then it would to stay in and by that
time you almost get on holiday you'll
probably be exhausted from all the extra
steps you've had to take
from july the 19th the westminster
government
says fully vaccinated passengers from
england
won't have to isolate on their return
from amber list countries
under 18s will also be exempt from
quarantining even though
they haven't been vaccinated yet and
everyone will still
have to factor in the cost of covered
tests
which could run into hundreds of pounds
for families
and still the rules could change at any
time
as many of us know from personal travel
experience
the government won't hesitate to act if
required and the data suggests
that needs to happen in other words to
put this on the record
an ambulance country could still turn
red
necessitating a change in uh behaviour
when we
return to the uk airports in the uk
are still running at a tiny fraction of
their capacity
school holidays are just about to begin
you know we believe that we should be
making the most of the success
of the vaccination program not just here
in the uk but obviously across the
broader europe is now is now catching up
but also we feel that the parameters are
there now to allow
relatively risk-free travel in a safe
way
but importantly removes the excessive
cost of testing that still remains
airlines welcomed the change but said
the government
should go further the boss of easyjet
johann lundgren
said with unnecessary testing staying in
place
more needs to be done we do not want to
see a return to flying
being a preserve of the rich and
expensive testing could sadly make
travel out of reach for some
this summer andy's bookings are still 95
down and that means there are bargains
to be had
some absolutely cracking deals around
for the next couple of months for
summer and 2021 there's still free child
places around
on certain family holidays because
demand and sales
have naturally been slow for andy the
quarantine cut is the best news he's had
in 12 months
but it's next summer's bookings that are
looking buoyant
recovery is still some time away
lisa dowd sky news sutton coalfield